just to throw some numbers as of
May 27th 2023 there are six million
6.66 million articles in the English
Wikipedia containing over 4.3 billion
words
including uh articles the total number
of pages is 58 million yeah uh does that
blow your mind I mean yes it does I mean
it doesn't because I I know those
numbers and see them from time to time
but in another sense a deeper sense yeah
it does I mean it's really uh remarkable
I remember when uh English Wikipedia
passed 100 000 articles and when German
Wikipedia passed 100 000 because I
happen to be in Germany with a bunch of
wikipedians that night and
um you know then it seemed quite big I
mean we knew at that time that it it was
nowhere near complete I remember at
wikimania in Harvard uh when we when we
did our annual conference there in
Boston
um someone
who had come to the conference from
Poland had brought along with him a
small encyclopedia a single volume uh
Encyclopedia of biographies so short
biography is normally a paragraph or so
about famous people in Poland and there
were some 22 000 entries and he pointed
out that even then 2006 Wikipedia felt
quite big and he said in English
Wikipedia there's only a handful of
these you know less than 10 percent I
think he said and so then you realize
yeah actually you know who was the mayor
of Warsaw in
1873 don't know probably not in English
Wikipedia but it probably might be today
but there's so much out there and of
course what we get into when we're
talking about how many entries there are
and how many you know how many could
there be is this very deep philosophical
issue of notability
um which is the question of well how do
you how do you draw the limit how do you
draw you know what what is there so
sometimes people say oh there should be
no limit but I think that doesn't stand
up to much scrutiny if you really pause
and think about it so I see in your hand
there you've got a Bic pen pretty
standard everybody's seen you know
billions of those in life classic though
it's a classic clear big pen so could we
have an entry about that big pen oil I
bet we do that type of big pen uh
because it's classic everybody knows it
and it's got a history and
um actually there's something
interesting about the big company they
make pens they also make kayaks
and there's something else they're
famous for basically uh they're they're
sort of a definition by non-essentials
company anything that's long
and plastic that's what they make wow so
if you want to find the common form the
platonic form of a big but could we have
an article about that very big pen
in your hand so Lex Friedman's big pen
out of this oh the very this is a very
specific instance and the answer is no
there's not much known about it I dare
say unless you know it's very special to
you and your great grandmother gave it
to you or something you probably know
very little about it it's a pen it's
just here in the office and
um so that that's just to show there's a
there's there is a limit I mean in
German Wikipedia they used to talk about
the the rear nut of the wheel of
ulifook's bicycle the well-known
wikipedian of the time to sort of
illustrate like you can't have an
article about literally everything and
so then it raises the question what can
you have an article about what can't do
and that can vary depending on the
subject matter
um one of the areas where we try to be
much more careful would be biographies
the reason is a biography of a living
person
if you get it wrong it can actually be
quite hurtful quite damaging and so if
someone is a private person
um and somebody tries to create a
Wikipedia there's no way to update it
there's not much now so for example an
encyclopedia article about my mother my
mother school teacher later a pharmacist
wonderful woman but never been in the
news I mean other than me talking about
why there shouldn't be a Wikipedia entry
that's probably made it in somewhere
standard example but you know there's
not enough known and you could sort of
Imagine a database of genealogy having
date of birth date of death and you know
so certain elements like that of of
private people but you couldn't really
write a biography one of the areas this
comes up quite often is uh what we call
blp1a we've got lots of acronyms
biography of a living person who's
notable for only one event there's a
real sort of danger zone and the type of
example would be a victim of a crime so
someone who's a victim of a famous
serial killer but about whom like really
not much is known they weren't a public
person they're just a victim of a crime
we really shouldn't have an article
about that person they'll be mentioned
of course and maybe the specific crime
might have an article but for that
person no not really that's not really
something that makes any sense because
how can you write a biography about
someone you don't know much about
and this is you know it varies from from
field to field so for example for many
academics we will have an entry that we
might not have in a different context
because for an academic
it's important to have sort of their
career you know what papers they've
published things like that you may not
know anything about their personal life
but that's actually not encyclopedically
relevant in the same way that it is for
member of a royal family where it's
basically all about the family so you
know we we're fairly nuanced about
notability and where it comes in and
I've always thought that the the term
notability I think is a little
problematic I mean it's we we struggle
about how to talk about it the problem
with notability is it's it can feel
insulting so no that you're not
noteworthy my mother's noteworthy she's
a really important person in my life
right so that's not right but it's more
like verifiability is there a way to to
get information that actually makes an
encyclopedia entry